ومعي في الاستوديو زميل وسيم الاحمر اهلا
بيكاسين ما التحدي الاساسي اذا نادي
توجهه او تطرحه هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
طبعا الاول مره يكاد يكون لدينا حكومه
بهذا التشدد كما وصفت لكن تجمع خصوم بهذه
الدرجه بمعنى انها تجمع مناهضي ال همم
المثليين للمثليين لهم حقوق المثليين همم
تجمع مؤيدين الاستيطان ومؤيد نظام الاراضي
الفلسطينيه واعتبار ان اسرائيل لها الحق
الحصري في كل الاراضي بمعنى نصف كامل لاي
همم تسويه ممكنه مع
الفلسطينيين حتى في الاراضي ال همم 48
مثلا همم المشكله مع السلطه القضائيه ومع
استقلال القضاء تكريس واعطاء همم
وجود سياسي لمؤيد الفوقيه ال- همم اليه
كل هذا
يجمعهم نتنياهو في الحكومه اليمنيه
المتطرفه التي بدات الان في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ولكن يجب تذكير ايضا انها لم
تاتي من فراغ الى انتخابات الديمقراطيه هي
نتيجه ايضا لسنوات من توجه يمين في
المجتمع الاسرائيلي بما فيه في التعليم
التدين في همم في التعليم الذي سيزداد على
الارجح الان مع تسليم هذه الحقائب لوزراء
يؤيدون توجهه ديني اكثر في مجال التعليم
هذه التحديات الاساسيه المتعلقه في الشكل
المجتمع الاسرائيلي والتكريس لهذا
الانقسام الذي بدانا نشهد همم الحصاد
وبوادر تجليات لهم هذه المظاهرات في طبيعه
الحال لان هذه الحكومه لديها مشكله
بالدرجه الاولى مع الاسرائيليين معانا
داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي هذا الانقسام ليس
فقط كمعارضه مثلا يساريه او غير او حتى
داخل مين معارضه
لنتنياهو داخل الكود هناك انقسامات ايضا
مشكله مع الراي العام مشكله بطبيعه الحال
مع
الفلسطينيين مع ناس في كل امكانيه لاي
تسويه لاي اعطاء حقل اي فلسطين حتى خسرتها
في الاراضي المحتله او في القدس كانت
نتنياهو اليوم
والتفاق او وثيقه الائتلاف يعتبر الاراضي
مثل همم بما فيها الجولان المحتل اراضي
اسرائيليه غير قابله للمساواه غير قابله
لها تسويه هناك مشكله كبرى مع اسرائيل مع
فلسطين وهذا يعني ان في ظل انسداد اي افق
احتمال الصدام احتمال المواجهه سيصبح اكبر
بكثير من مكان قائمه لانه اصلا يجب
التذكير لم يكن هناك عمليات السلام لم
يكون فوضى السلام حتى الحكومات السابقه
كان هناك نوع من الاداره في همم سنوات
الاخيره الان هذه المشكله تتعمق اكثر
وتطرح ايضا مشكله هذه الحكومه مع فا
الولايات المتحده وخاصه همم عفوا حلفاء
اسرائيل وخاصه الولايات المتحده
عن
واشنطن كيف ستتعامل مع هذه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الجديده يعني هناك همم
تصريحات خرجت على لسان وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي قبل تسلم هذه الحكومه
لمنصبها لتوليها السلطه يحذر مثلا همم
الاراضي الفلسطينيه بشكل رسمي من قبل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ويعتبر ان هذا لا يجب
ان يحصل وان الولايات المتحده ستعارض لم
تعترف الى اخره وهناك معلومات ايضا ان
السفير الامريكي في اسرائيل نقل نوع من
التحضيرات الخطوط الحدود التي لا يجب ان
تتجاوزها الحكومه المقبله منها مساله الضم
الاراضي مساله همم القدس يا شباب الهيكل
حسب عدم تغيير الوضع القائم لان من هذا من
شان تاجيج ااا المواجهات في المرحله
المقبله ان حصل وخاصه مع وجود شخص مثل
كثير مثلا على راس الامن الداخلي ونعرف
مثلا انه له ثوابق في هذا الشان مساله
الاستفزاز في باحد الاقصى وغيرها هناك
تحذيرات امريكيه اذا تعلق مساله الحقوق
المتعلقه بالمثليين مساله استقلال القضاء
عدم تجاوزه لهذا يطرح سؤال كانت الحكومه
المقبله الحكومه نتانيه او ستتريث بخطوات
عمليه لتنفيذ هذا البرنامج الذي اعلنت عنه
وان كانت كيف سيتعامل مع حلفاء داخل
الحكومه حتى لا يغضب الحليف مثلا الامريكي
لكن هناك نقطه ايضا اساسيه تؤخذ بعيد
الاعتبار هي كيف سيطاف الخاصه اليهود همم
في الخارج في الولايات المتحده بشكل لون
داعم اساسي همم لاسرائيل مع الحكومه
الجديده هذا سؤال مهم جدا في همم الايام
تربيع والاشهر المرحله المقبله ان كان
هناك تغير على طبيعه هذه العلاقه لان هذا
له دور اساسي في همم السياسه الخارجيه
للولايات المتحده لكن لاسرائيل ايضا